singer r.kelly is back in jail this
morning for not paying his child support
bills he was arrested yesterday in
Chicago after he failed to pay more than
160 $1000 he allegedly owes that
happened just hours after Gail's
explosive interview with him first aired
Kelley also faces ten charges of
aggravated criminal sexual abuse court
documents allege three of his four
accusers were underage at the time
Kelley has pleaded not guilty the two
women that Kelley lives with are Azrael
Clary and Joycelyn savage they were in
court as he was arraigned on those
charges last week their parents say they
believe the singer has brainwashed them
we asked our Kelley about allegations
that he lured these young women with
promises of helping their singing
careers now Kelley claims it was savages
mother who pushed him on the issue
she started promoting that Joyce thing
could sing and she was a singer and
she's trying to be a singer and you know
wanted me to produce her or whatever I
said well you know let her sing she sang
and she couldn't sing but how does it go
from she can't sing you don't think she
has a talent that you like but she ends
up being with you spending when I saw
her on stage nothing about her told me
she's saying I don't have yes you know I
can't say oh that girl sing it's because
she was beautiful well we then
interviewed Ezreal Clary
and Joyce and savage with our Kelly who
was standing nearby even though his team
had told us he would not be in the room
he entered after the interview began
they told us that their parents are just
looking for money which both sets of
parents deny do either of you want to
sing no no none of you have any singing
ambitions no no that's a lot that's
another lie yeah that's another lie
trust me no we did hear that you wanted
to say yeah that you want interesting so
let me tell you something about singing
actually okay before I even met our
Kelly I told my parents I did not want
to sing my parents made singing like a
job for me it is not something I wanted
to do and not only that I even tried to
kill myself
because I did not want to sing as to cry
out for help to tell them this is not
what I want to do with my life this is
not how I want to spend my life
your father told me that that you tried
to take your life and that the only
thing that made you happy was singing no
and that's why he to help you no no
neither one of you want to sing what do
you want to do in terms of a job or
career are you happy just doing what
you're doing honestly I'm happy doing
what I'm doing I haven't figured out
what I want to do with my life but I
know when that time comes we know Rob is
go support us regardless right Oh most
definitely
he's our full support and we his full
support and all we need is each other
Jericka Duncan is outside the Cook
County Jail in Chicago where our Kellie
is in custody with their response from
McCleary and the savage families Jericka
good morning good morning Azrael and
Joycelyn parents both say that they
never received any money from our
kellian as you just heard in that clip
Azrael says that she actually tried to
attempt suicide because of her parents
pressuring her to sing well CBS News
reviewed medical records and according
to those medical records Azrael told
doctors at the time that the suicide
attempt was triggered by issues with her
then-boyfriend
she told them music helped calm her down
and in the lifetime DocuSign are kelly
Clara's parents say it was Azrael who
was pushing to become a famous singer
and work with Kelly they claimed they
told Azrael she could not be alone with
Kelly if she worked with him I didn't
think it was a good fit I didn't want to
have any part of it but Azrael actually
pressed us she made her little threats
about if we didn't you know let her do
this which she would do at a news
conference yesterday Joycelyn savages
parents said they had proof it was Kelly
who arranged for Joycelyn to meet him
they said they were disturbed by his
interview when I saw on TV this morning
about his wakey act when he got upset I
can only imagine what he does
in behind closed doors I sit there and I
want to not just pray for my daughter
but pray for mr. Kelly to get some type
of healing now about 30 minutes after
the news conference Joycelyn contacted
her family for the first time in two
years
she called their lawyer's office and
said that she is happy now a manager for
our Kelly said that he would facilitate
an in-person reunion for the savages as
early as next week
Joyce Ling's parents also said though
that they want a mental health expert to
be with him Liana
Thank You Jenny say something to jurika
druga I'm glad you pointed out about the
medical records because mr. Clary as
riyals father told me the exact same
thing the reason why she committed
suicide to commit suicide tried to take
her own life
was because she had had a very messy
breakup with a boyfriend so I'm glad
that you have medical you have
documentation that actually backs up
what he is saying Thank You tarika I
mean it's a sad story as you mentioned
all the way around and it's so
complicated and there's so many layers
it's very complicated and just very very
tawdry and messy but hopefully there
will be a resolution very soon thank you
very much of course any young girl Kent
has the right to change her mind and her
career ambitions but yes seems to be a
bit more than just that that's a good
point